I hope you all understand that I'm
taking this super seriously [ __ ] off
blendy other guys Justin Bieber oh my
god oh my god oh no look out Justin
Bieber it's a ninja Wow good job
JB's you got that ninja ha there was a
guy with an axe right behind you used
about to kill you oh okay oh this looks
wrong oh but it feels so right he'll
destroy you if you wait and take the
lift to the wah oh no no he destroyed me
all right take two greatest not products
rainbow rope swing lots of rope swings
this week oh is it with this character
and getting stuck ah
y'all are dicks I'm the greatest you
obviously can't handle my aah tank
eleventy ha huh no man I thought I know
how to beat you now ha ha ha ha
right up your balls
okay now taking this very slowly cuz
death awaits around every corner huh
made it odd to greatest ha oh okay okay
nobody kill way miss me Oh Pogo Park are
late
epic tricks Wow oh yeah oh yeah nailed
it this part is hard just like I'm not
going there huh oh I meant amiss need to
get back a bit huh
nailed it [ __ ] how get off my lawn hey
that's even though my house is
exceptionally ugly you all need to get
the [ __ ] off my lawn impossible miss me
stay here
Oh balls Oh balls oh okay alright here
we go one last time I'm serious
I'm a serious murdering bastard I'm
gonna I could you thought you could get
away from me kid who thought that
vengeance would not be mine but you were
wrong just like you were wrong in
kindergarten
survival Hey whoa I didn't even get a
chance all right that's the way the
world works
oh wow you're bad shut the [ __ ] up
oh ha ha bounce it off my head for an
epic not win done huh me how my son get
me back on the bike I can still use my
legs oh you're the baby's coming
the baby's got a son my baby's coming
baby
kill them all I thought the Explo what
what happened use the Force
oh this is super effective okay all
right let's do this correctly assignment
buddy come here friend yeah just head
now you're a dog
whoa whoa justice done Poochie good job
son
super weapon throw with Santa Walsh I
was too far
this has been happy wheels highlights
thanks for watching if you like with
your son you want to see more why not
subscribe to my channel want to help the
channel grow
leave a like add in to your favorites or
share it with your friends on Facebook
and Twitter thanks again and as always I
will see you in the next video